Debra is with us Debra's in Denver
Colorado
hi Debra welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave thank you
I am I completely turned into a dork
because I've always leased cars because
I like them shiny and new and now I am
selling my car because I'm the Dave dork
and I'm excited about it I mean it's on
my car and get another one but I don't
know how to do it I've never sold a car
before and I have a question is and I
need the cash from the car to get my
Dave car so I don't understand how it
all works if you could please explain
that to me okay and so do you use the
car least now no okay no I just
I bought after the lease is it paid for
and I'm paying on it oh you have a debt
on it I do how much do you owe on it
about nine thousand what will it be
going up for sale for about twelve and
you're going to use the three to buy
your car yeah okay all right so you put
it up for sale for twelve someone hands
you a check for 12,000 you take the
12,000 down to the bank and pay off the
car they will either hand you the title
or mail you the title meantime the buyer
has the car and a bill of sale from you
and they're you and the buyer are
waiting on the title to come in from the
bank and you sign the title over to them
as soon as you can get it whether you
pick it up or not where is it financed
[Music]
through Bank of America okay do you bank
with Bank of America locally or did it
just happen to lend there no it landed
there okay all right then be in touch
with them and ask them what the process
is to get the title and how fast you can
get it after the pay off well okay so
based on what you just said here's my
question after I sell this car and the
people drive away with it do I walk to
the bank I mean I guess you'd run okay
you might rent a car for a day or two
okay and you know it's better for me
that I mean I'm guessing it's better for
me to have another Curran lined up for
me to purchase if you found it but you
have you don't have the money to buy it
until you get them car sold right that's
what you're telling me right yeah all
right you don't have any money in
savings right now right not enough to
buy a car buy a $3,000 car okay so yeah
you're probably gonna call dollar car
rental and have you a car rental set up
and you're gonna rent a car for a couple
days okay and then go you know go to the
bank get your money give the bank nine
thousand walk out with three thousand go
buy your three thousand dollar car take
your date if you've got it already lined
up that's fine if you know where it is
where it's sitting but that's how you
just you just got to think through the
logistics but go ahead and call B of a
because Bank of America is a pain in the
butt they're so large then they have no
brains and so you know you need to call
them and find out what the process is to
get this title you don't want this buyer
waiting on this title six or eight weeks
because Bank of America can't find there
but with both hands and so you've got to
have that all kind of lined up to get
that title ready to come towards you and
what that process is so that you can get
the people title because they can't get
tags on it till they get the title in
most states sometimes you can do it the
bill of sale but most places you're
gonna need the title sometimes it's done
online now so maybe you can get that
pulled off you just got to see how your
state works